ein Hinweis vorab in dieser Folge wird
die Szenerie nach den Abstürzen auf
Wiesen und Wald bei Überlingen
geschildert denjenigen den solche
Beschreibungen zu nahe gehen raten wir
vom Hören ab
hallo mein Name ist Sky Duo und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall eure Host Natalie
Strauß und Mirko Kasimir öffnen
Fallakten vom Mord an Ramses den dritten
bis zum Kannibalen von Rotenburg
und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß hallo
und herzlich willkommen zu unserem
Tatort deutschland-spezial einen Monat
lang präsentiert Bild euch täglich von
Montag bis Freitag spektakuläre True
Crime Fälle von der Antike bis in die
Gegenwart als Radiomoderatorin begegnen
mir in unseren Nachrichten fast täglich
Kriminalfälle bei denen es mir wirklich
eiskalt den Rücken runterläuft da gibt
es Fälle die uns nicht loslassen selbst
wenn sie lange zurückliegen oder ja mit
unserem Alltag scheinbar gar nichts zu
tun haben und keiner kann euch diese
Stories dazu besser erzählen als
Sprecher und Moderatoren Mirko Kasimir
hey Mirko ich freue mich riesig dass ihr
das zusammen machen dürfen und ja jetzt
zusammen durchziehen können hello hi
grüß Dich Natalie und vielen Dank für
die Vorschuss Lorbeeren glaub mir die
Freude ist ganz meinerseits weißt du es
gibt einfach Geschichten die uns noch
Jahre und manchmal sogar Jahrhunderte
später noch beschäftigen toll dass wir
ein paar von hier aufgreifen können der
Fall den wir euch jetzt erzählen der
liegt inzwischen 20 Jahre zurück wer von
euch alt genug ist wird sich mit
Sicherheit daran erinnern es ist eine
Geschichte die mit einer unfassbaren
Reihe von Fehlern und Zufällen beginnt
die zu einer schrecklichen Katastrophe
führten Mirko leg los am 1 Juli 2002
stoßen am Himmel über Süddeutschland
eine Frachtmaschine und ein
Passagierflugzeug zusammen das
Flugzeugunglück von Überlingen ist bis
heute die schwerste luftfahrtkatastrophe
der Bundesrepublik 71 Menschen sterben
davon 49 Kinder das Schlimmste was
Eltern passieren kann das muss man sich
mal überlegen ihre eigenen Kinder zu
überleben ich meine ich habe keine
Kinder ich kann mich da nicht 100%
reinversetzen aber es klingt einfach nur
grausam und der Gedanke dass diese
kleinen unschuldigen Kinderseelen die
kaum Zeit auf diesen Planeten verbracht
haben so etwas durchmachen mussten es
lässt mich nicht los
aber diese Katastrophe lieber Mirko ist
ja eigentlich kein Verbrechen oder naja
es war zumindest kriminelle
Fahrlässigkeit im Spiel aber du hast
Recht Natalie heute geht es eigentlich
um ein Verbrechen das erst anderthalb
Jahre später stattfand wie ist aber so
oft ist müssen wir in der Geschichte
etwas weiter zurückgehen um das
Verbrechen zu verstehen und wie es dazu
kam alles beginnt 10.000 Meter über dem
Erdboden in den Abendstunden des ersten
Juli 2002 sind die wetter- und
Sichtverhältnisse über Süddeutschland
ausgezeichnet die Sonne ist schon vor
einer ganzen Weile untergegangen
bashkurian Airlines Flug 2937 ist gut
zwei Stunden zuvor vom Flughafen Moskau
automotive wo gestartet und unterwegs
nach Barcelona die Stimmung an Bord der
Passagiermaschine vom Typ tupoleftio 154
m ist ausgelassen im Passagierbereich
plappern dutzende Kinderstimmen
Durcheinander an Bord befinden sich 49
Schülerinnen und Schüler im Alter von 8
bis 16 Jahren dazu noch einige
Lehrerinnen ihre Eltern und
Betreuerinnen die Reise nach Barcelona
ist eine Auszeichnung für die meist
hochbegabten Kinder die zu den besten
ihrer Schulen in der kleinen russischen
Teilrepublik Baschkortostan im Kaukasus
gehören
hinzu kommen noch neuen
Besatzungsmitglieder bestehend aus der
Cockpit Crew unter dem Kommando des sehr
erfahrenen Kapitäns Alexander gross und
der Kabinencrew die gerade einen kleinen
abends nicht für die Kids und Sekt für
die Erwachsenen serviert ebenfalls auf
10000 m Höhe ist eine Frachtmaschine vom
Typ Boeing 757 des Logistikunternehmens
DHL unterwegs Flugnummer 611 von Bahrain
über Bergamo nach Brüssel hier sitzen
nur Pilot Paul Philipps aus
Großbritannien und seinem kanadischer
Kollege Brand campioni als Copilot im
Cockpit in regelmäßigen Abständen geben
beide Crews ihre Flugdaten an das ac/dc
das area Control Center in Zürich weiter
das ist unter anderem für den
süddeutschen Luftraum zuständig und wird
von der Flug regierungsgesellschaft
Skyguide betrieben das heißt ihr hört es
schon selber es klingt nach einem ganz
normalen Flugtag am Himmel über Europa
das Wetter ist wundervoll die Piloten
sind super geschult haben viel Erfahrung
nichts deutet darauf hin dass ich hier
jetzt gerade ein riesiges Unheil
zusammenbraut Mirko erzähl mal bitte
weiter gegen halb 12 nachts bietet der
Pilot der dhl-maschine auf 11.000 Meter
steigen zu dürfen und holt sich dafür
beim zuständigen Fluglotsen von Skyguide
Peter Nielsen die Erlaubnis sein dieser
bestätigt dass Manöver übersieht aber
dass sich die russische Maschine mit den
Kindern an Bord mittlerweile ebenfalls
auf dieser Flughöhe befindet ein paar
Minuten später schlagen die
automatischen annäherungssensoren der
Flugzeuge in beiden Cockpits Alarm das
allein ist noch kein großes Drama denn
dafür sind sie da da auch der Fluglotse
Peter Nielsen sieht die beiden Maschinen
auf Kollisionskurs fliegen aber es gibt
Prozeduren für solche Fälle
der Fluglotse weist die Maschine des
russischen Piloten Alexander gross an
sofort zu sinken aber Nielsen bekommt
keine Bestätigung aus dem Cockpit der
tupolef doch wenig später sinkt die
Maschine tatsächlich das Problem stand
damit für Fluglotse Peter Nielsen gelöst
und er wendet sich einer anderen Aufgabe
zu denn der Kontrollraum ist an diesem
Abend unterbesetzt ja aber für ihn ist
es eigentlich klar okay ich habe diese
Aufgabe jetzt beendet kann zur nächsten
überschreiten und wenn ein Fluglotse in
dem Kapitän die Anweisung gibt hey bitte
sinken dann macht man das ja als Kapitän
auch mag man meinen ja es sollte immer
alles so einfach sein ist es aber nicht
da hast du vollkommen Recht sollte man
weinen denn natürlich sind moderne
Flugzeuge mit Bordcomputern und
Kollisionswarnsystem ausgestattet und
die reagieren logischerweise schneller
als Menschen und berechnen mögliche
Ausweis Szenarien die dann an die
cockpit-crew ausgegeben werden
diese Bordcomputer der Flugzeuge in der
Luft interagieren miteinander und so
kommunizieren auch die beiden bautechner
der Tupolev und der Boeing und stimmen
sich ab um einen Zusammenstoß zu
verhindern nach der Anweisung vom
Fluglotsen Peter Nielsen zum Sinken
herrscht im Cockpit der tupolef aber
kurz Verwirrung denn der Bordcomputer
gibt nämlich gleichzeitig die
gegenteilige Anweisung zum sofortigen
steigen während der Computer in der
Frachtmaschine sofortiges sinken für die
Kuh empfiehlt hier ist natürlich
blitzschnelles entscheidend gefragt ja
es gibt widersprüchliche Aussagen was
machen wir nun so die Crew der
russischen Maschine vertraut dem
Fluglotsen die Crew der DHL hört auf den
Bordcomputer und das hat zur Folge dass
beide Maschinen an höher verlieren
richtig beide Flugzeuge gehen in den
Singflug und das ist das Todesurteil für
71 Menschen
Peter Nielsen gibt zudem noch eine
falsche Flugrichtung an die Piloten der
Tupolev weiter beide Maschinen fliegen
jetzt fast genau in einem rechten Winkel
aufeinander zu noch gibt es die
Möglichkeit dass sie sich im riesigen
leeren Himmel über dem Bodensee und
aufgrund ihrer hohen Geschwindigkeit
verfehlen aber es kommt leider alles
unmögliche zusammen und hier kommen wir
wirklich zu dem entsetzlichen Teil beide
Maschinen kollidieren
um 23:35 Uhr durchtrennt das
Seitenleitwerk der Boeing den Rumpf der
russischen Maschine kurz vor dem
Tragflächen das Seitenleitwerk ist die
am Heck des Flugzeugs senkrecht in die
Höhe wagende Flosse und die zerschneidet
die Tupolev buchstäblich die
Passagiermaschine zerbricht und
explodiert teilweise in einem Feuerball
den einige Menschen der Regionen vom
Boden aus beobachten stürzt das frag in
die Tiefe Trümmer und Leichen werden auf
einer 30 Quadratkilometer Großfläche um
die Ortschaften Owingen und Überlingen
verteilt die DHL Maschine ist ebenfalls
schwer beschädigt und stürzt 8 km weiter
nördlich ab schon kurz darauf sind alle
Feuerwehren der Region deutsche und
schweizerische unterwegs zur
Unglücksstelle aber Sie können nur noch
brennende Trümmer löschen
unter ihnen 49 Kindern
deshalb lässt mich das einfach nicht los
all diese Kinder und dazu auch die
Eltern die zu dieser Unglückstelle eilen
müssen den wird Bescheid gegeben da ist
was ganz fürchterliches passiert die
Kinder sind in einem Flugzeug du weißt
oh mein Gott ich muss mich hier auf das
allerschlimmste einstellen und die
Eltern machen sich auf den Weg nach
Überlingen die Angehörigen müssen nun
ihre Kinder identifizieren und einer
dieser Angehörigen ist Vitali Kalorien
er ist Bauingenieur und damals 46 Jahre
alt seine beiden Kinder waren an Bord
und auch seine Ehefrau die sie nach
Barcelona begleiten sollte erst einer
der ersten der dort an der Unglückstelle
eintrifft ist schon am Tag danach in
Überlingen und hilft bei dem
Bergungsarbeiten erst der ganz engagiert
mit bei der Sache er sieht Trümmer er
sieht Leichen in den Gärten und
schließlich findet er tatsächlich den
leblosen Körper seiner vierjährigen
Tochter die hat sich in so einem ja in
so Ästen eines Baumes verfangen und er
hilft der Feuerwehr sie aus diesen Ästen
zu befreien jetzt muss man sich das mal
verbildlichen es ist dein eigenes totes
Kind dass du da wirkst später trifft er
auch auf seinen jungen der es auf dem
Asphalt angekommen bei seiner Frau ist
der Zustand so schlimm gewesen dass ihm
die Identifizierung erspart wurde und da
frage ich mich wie er trägt ein Mensch
sowas das macht ja auch was mit dir wie
geht er denn in Zukunft weiterhin damit
um Mirko ja zunächst scheint Vitali
Kalorien erstmal stark zu sein denn er
engagiert sich sehr stark er betreut die
anderen Hinterbliebenen setzt sich ein
und fordert Aufklärungen in alle
Richtungen da gibt es eine Menge
aufzuklären denn die Unfallursachen sind
vielfältig das sind beispielsweise die
gegensätzlichen Anweisungen des
Fluglotsen und des kollisionswarnsystems
üblicherweise gelten die Anweisungen des
Bordcomputers als vorrangig zu den
Anweisungen eines Fluglotsen am Boden
die Piloten der Tupolew haben sich aber
nicht an diese Konvention gehalten aber
auch die Piloten der Boeing haben Fehler
gemacht unter anderem haben sie die
geforderte SIM-Karte nicht umgesetzt und
ihr Kollisionswarnsystem auf eine zu
geringe Reichweite eingestellt die
Hauptschuld aber scheint bei der
flugsicherungsgesellschaft Skyguide und
dem Fluglotsen Peter Nielsen zu liegen
die Station in Zürich war unterbesetzt
und ein Kollege Nielsens war in der
Pause und so musste er Peter Nielsen
mindestens zwei herausfordernde Jobs
gleichzeitig erledigen
Peter Nielsen hätte diese Überlastung
sofort erkennen und melden müssen ich
spekuliere jetzt mal an dieser Stelle
ein bisschen rum ich meine wir merken ja
alle schon dass es hier ganz viele
Ereignisse gibt die so eigentlich nicht
hätten laufen sollen ich frag mich was
ist denn bei diesen Peter Nielsen im
Kopf abgegangen also hat er einfach
nicht gemerkt dass er total überfordert
ist und dass diese Situation absolut
unzumutbar ist oder vielleicht hat er
sich sogar gar nicht erst getraut seinem
Chef zu sagen nee so kann ich nicht
arbeiten also hat er sich
zusammengerissen und gesagt das packe
ich schon das ist jetzt aber nicht alles
da kommen noch weitere Dinge hinzu die
Telefonanlage die hat nicht funktioniert
und da frage ich mich wie das überhaupt
möglich ist dann so einer Position das
ist total wichtig dass man dort erreicht
werden kann und im Zweifel auch Leute
anrufen kann denn die
bezirkskontrollstelle der Flugsicherung
in Karlsruhe die wollte nämlich auf
diese drohende Kollision Hinweisen
allerdings sind sie nicht durchgekommen
all diese Telefonanlage gewartet wurde
also es ist unglaublich wie viele
Probleme Fehlentscheidung Zufälle und
und und hier zusammenkommen damit sowas
erst passiert das war meine erste Frage
die ich mir gestellt habe wie ist es
überhaupt möglich an so einem riesigen
Himmel zu kollidieren wie kann das sein
das ist der schier unmöglich aber es
gibt halt Flugkorridore und diese
Flugzeuge haben ganz streng festgelegte
Routen auf denen sie sich bewegen ja
diese Straßen die sehen wir als normal
Bürger gar nicht die sind aber für alle
Beteiligten total klar und ähm man weiß
ganz genau wie man sich dort zu bewegen
hat nach der Katastrophe gibt es viele
Verfahren um Schadenersatz für die
Hinterbliebenen Mitarbeiter von Sky
Guide werden wegen fahrlässiger Tötung
verurteilt hohe Versicherungssummen
werden bezahlt die bei scaryan Airline
geht an den Wiedergutmachungszahlungen
pleite
aber natürlich nichts davon macht
Menschen wieder lebendig oder nimmt den
Angehörigen ihre Trauer oder ihre Wut
und damit sind wir wieder bei Vitali
Kalojew der Unfall lässt ihm keine Ruhe
der stämmige kaukasische Bauingenieur
hat alles verloren
er will Peter Nielsen den nach seiner
Ansicht einzigen Schuldigen den Mann der
die Anweisung zum Singflug gegeben hat
zur Rede stellen und von ihm eine
persönliche Entschuldigung
vielleicht will er das Nielsen seinen
Schmerz sieht und spürt doch Skyguide
schirmt den Fluglotsen von der
Öffentlichkeit ab verständlicherweise
Peter Nielsen hat seine Strafe erhalten
und muss mit seiner Schuld leben aber er
lebt und seine Familie auch zusammen mit
Frau und Kind wohnt Peter Nielsen im
Februar 2004 in Kloten das ist in der
Nähe Zürichs das kleine aber moderne
Einfamilienhaus hat Terrasse und Garage
die Nachbarn sind nett doch der Mann der
dort an der Garage neben der Terrasse
steht und eine Zigarette nach der
anderen raucht scheint kein Nachbar zu
sein er ist dunkel gekleidet der Blick
müde die zwei Finger die die Zigarette
halten sind gelb vom Nikotin dieser Mann
ist Vitali Kalorien Einstein
sympathischer und wortgewandter Mann dem
im Angesicht der Flugzeugtrümmer und
Leichen das Herz brach
Peter Nielsen sieht den ihm unbekannten
Mann durch die Scheiben seines
Wohnzimmers und will ihn ansprechen
eigentlich müsste Peter Niesen schon auf
dem Arbeitsweg sein aber heute ging es
am Morgen etwas turbulent in der jungen
Familie zu Nielsens Frau hat ein
komisches Gefühl und möchte ihn
eigentlich davon abhalten zu dem Fremden
hinauszugehen doch der zieht sich schon
seine Jacke über und läuft über die
Terrasse wo Kalorien jetzt steif wie ein
grauer toter Baum steht
nächstens Frau kann nicht hören was
gesprochen wird doch dann sieht sie ein
Mann plötzlich zusammenbrechen über
alles Blut und der fremde Mann hat ein
Messer in der Hand dass er jetzt fallen
lässt Peters Frau stirbt mit dem Kind
nach draußen Peter liegt auf dem Boden
Kalorien dreht sich um und geht
schweigend davon die letzten Worte Peter
Nielsen richte die an seine Frau bitte
ruf einen Krankenwagen bitte ruf einen
Krankenwagen
es ist das nächste Opfer in der
Katastrophe von Überlingen somit sind es
mittlerweile 72 Menschen am nächsten Tag
lässt sich Kalorien in seinem Hotel
widerstandslos festnehmen im späteren
Verfahren gibt er vor von der Tötung
nichts mitbekommen zu haben er nur eine
Entschuldigung gewollt das Gericht
erkennt eine teilweise
Unzurechnungsfähigkeit an er wird wegen
vorsätzlicher Tötung nicht wegen Mordes
zu 8 Jahren Haft verurteilt die nach
einer Revision auf fünf Jahre und drei
Monate herabgesetzt werden wer jetzt
denkt wow was ist das denn für eine
Geschichte das ist immer noch nicht das
Ende der Geschichte ja da gibt es noch
einen ziemlich krassen Twist den ich
persönlich auch recht verstörend finde
2007 wird Vitali Kalorien vorzeitig aus
der Haft entlassen und kehrt in die
russische Teil Republik Nord Ostsee
ziehen zurück bei seiner Ankunft
empfangen ihn hunderte Mitglieder der
Putin treuen Jugendorganisation
Jugend bezeichnet wird
feiern ihn als Held als jemand der für
Gerechtigkeit gesorgt hat im Jahr 2008
wird er zum stellvertretenden Minister
für Bau und Architektur von
nord-ostsetien alanien an Land und
bleibt in dieser Position bis 2016 als
er schließlich in den Ruhestand geht
verleiht ihm die lokale Regierung den
höchsten Orden die Medaille zum Ruhm aus
Siziliens für die besten Leistungen die
Verbesserung der Lebensbedingungen der
Einwohner der Region die Ausbildung der
jüngeren Generation und
festhalten die Aufrechterhaltung von
Recht und Ordnung habt ihr das gerade
gehört
aufrecht Erhaltung von Recht und Ordnung
wir sprechen hier über einen Mann der
hat zwar alles verloren seine gesamte
Familie und da hatte auch unser vollstes
Mitgefühl gleichzeitig hatte einem
anderen Menschen das Leben genommen
und diese Person bekommt jetzt diesen
Orden dieser Auszeichnung diesen Ruhm
unter anderem für die Aufrechterhaltung
von Recht und Ordnung ich meine ich maße
mir nicht an nachvollziehen zu können
wie sich dieser Schmerz anfühlt oder wie
man im Anschluss mit so einem endlosen
Schmerz umgeht aber gleichzeitig nehme
ich mir dennoch heraus zu sagen dass
rechtfertigt keine Selbstjustiz ja man
wünscht es jedem Angehörigen dass er in
irgendeiner Form wieder Freude am Leben
findet ja und das sei ihm auch zu 100%
gegönnt der soll alles bekommen alles
was dieses eigentlich wunderschöne Leben
für uns alle offenhält soll er haben
aber da ist diese Geschichte für mich
äußerst unstimmig und und gibt mir ein
sehr besorgniserregendes Gefühl er hat
es dann aber auch weiterhin geschafft
ein neues Leben aufzubauen also er hat
auch eine neue Frau und die hatten im
selben Jahr der Zeit nochmal Zwillinge
bekommen das war im Jahr 2018 und das
würde ich auch gerne mal als Anlass
nutzen dass wir hier auch über die
anderen Hinterbliebenen und auch Zeugen
sprechen ja weil die Anteilnahme an
dieser Katastrophe die war riesig in
dieser Region also es wurde ein ganz
bestimmter Verein gegründet und eine
Gedenkstätte eröffnet diese wird dann
auch von ortsansässigen und auch von den
Hinterbliebenen gemeinsam betreut und
das machen die ganz liebevoll es gibt
jedes Jahr gibt es einen Trauertag da
kommen alle zusammen man gedenkt der
Opfer man fühlt sich den natürlich auch
besonders nahe wenn man sich an diese
Absturzstelle begibt und man ist
verändert da und man begleitet sich
gegenseitig in dieser Trauer wir
sprechen hier über Mütter Väter
Geschwister und viele andere die diesen
Menschen den dieses Ereignis passiert
ist einfach nahe standen manche sind
sogar in der Region gezogen es haben
sich Freund Eigenschaften gebildet also
es klingt alles diesen grausamen
Umständen entsprechend harmonisch und
macht nicht den Anschein als hätte ich
hier irgendwer an Rache gedacht da hast
du vollkommen recht das war die
Geschichte und jedes Mal wenn ich sie
höre und darüber nachdenke dann finde
ich sie auf so vielen Ebenen trage und
einfach unfassbar schrecklich das ist
einfach ein Fall der einen nicht mehr
loslässt Natalie ganz genau man mag
vielleicht den ersten Impuls
nachvollziehen können den Vitali
Kalorien in seiner Trauer und seiner Wut
erlebt hat ich bin selber Vater einer
Tochter und möchte mir nicht anmaßen
dass ich den Schmerz und die Wut und die
Trauer die ihr empfindet nachvollziehen
kann aber das alles rechtfertigt
natürlich keine Selbstjustiz
das war was oder richtig ja jetzt müssen
wir erstmal ordentlich durchatmen was
für ein absolut krasserfall
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und hoffen
dass ihr bei der nächsten Folge wieder
dabei seid bei Tatort Deutschland
Spezial euer Mirko und eure Natalie die
Abstürze von Überlingen und ihre
mörderischen Folgen zeichnen wir nach
mit Artikeln der Bild-Zeitung der Welt
des SÜDKURIER sowie einer Chronik des
SWR
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haie
Produktion Serverdienst